Nice Talking with You: Travel.
We asked the students of Global Voices, "Where's a great place for everyone to visit...
...and why should they go there?"...
...and here's what they had to say.
Global Voices. Nice Talking with You.
Global Voices. Global Voices.
My favorite city in America...
...is San Francisco. It's a city where something is always happening.
The first time I went to San Francisco, it was the weekend where it was the Chinese New Year...
...and also, they were having a peace protest at the bay areas, Fisherman's Wharf.
There were angry protesters, then we saw all these celebrities,...
...and then that night was the Chinese New Year, and the streets were filled with dragons.
It was fun!
Tahiti.
There are lots of islands in Tahiti.
It was just an incredible, cultural mix.
They have like the native Polynesian, the French,...
...and the food was great, but what I loved the most was the scenery.
This most incredible scenery I remember, sitting in a lagoon,...
...the white sands and the crystal blue ocean,...
...sitting in the sea and just sitting there doing nothing. I wasn't swimming or anything...
...and I thought at that moment that this was heaven on Earth.
Global Voices.
Global Voices. This is Tom Kenny, author of "Nice Talking with You".
Check it out at www.nicetalkingwithyou.com.